how much do people have to kind of date
around to find somebody though because
it does take a bit of exploration to
find somebody you're compatible with so
by what age should people have figured
it out because i mean there's always the
grass looks greener so at some point
maybe you should just settle down but
what are your thoughts on that no matter
who you find they're going to be full of
flaws like you are and so a lot of it is
something you create you want to find
someone you can trust and someone that
you're attracted to and perhaps someone
who shares the same ambitions and then
pretty much all of it after that is what
you create rather than what you find and
i'm not suggesting that this is
necessarily a desirable alternative
there are many cultures that arrange
marriages and those arranged marriages
frequently work it's not obvious that
they work less frequently than
relationships or marriages that are
predicated on romantic attraction don't
overestimate the degree to which you
have to find someone versus create the
relationship